in this patreon q a i'll be answering a
bunch of life and anime related
questions
that were sent in by you guys as a
warning there will be manga spoilers for
my
academia specifically but no spoilers
for the other series that i receive
questions for
such as the promise neverland and attack
on titan if you want your questions
answered in the q a next month
then all you have to do is become a
patreon supporter or youtube member for
two dollars
by clicking one of the links in the
description thank you to everyone who
currently supports the channel i really
do appreciate it
and just before we begin my discord
server is now open to anyone and
everyone
previously it was only for patreon
supporters but now literally anyone can
join
all you got to do is click one of the
many links in the description and yeah
you'll join the server straight away
hopefully i'll see some of you there but
without further ado let's get into the
first question of this video
and this one comes from joseph joseph
says as far as we are aware
shigaraki did not steal any quirks upon
his awakening do you think he should
have
to answer this i would say that yes
shigaraki definitely should have stolen
some quirks
however you know clearly he did try to
take one for all
but yes he should have definitely tried
to take erasure i think because
we saw from the battle itself shigaraki
was not actually trying to get the
eurasia quirk
at one point he even threw the quote
destroying bullet at aizawa
all he cared about was stopping izawa
from uh from nullifying his powers
he didn't really try to steal the quirk
so i think he should have definitely
tried to do that
going forward though a power that i
think would be good is uh his overhaul
because we know that even though
overhaul lost his arms he still
technically has his quirk factor so i
think if shiguraki does get his hands on
overhaul
he could then just restore afo's body
and these two could like rule together
if any quirk could restore afo it would
be overhaul
because i mean the way he rearranges
mata it could totally happen
hell i mean overhaul even said that if
erie died if he got to her quick enough
he could restore her
so this this power is honestly one of
the most overpowered quirks in the
series
and but i think shiguraki should get his
hands on that if he gets the chance
the next question comes in from kronos
who is one of my longest patreon
supporters
so shout out to him and he says what are
your top three moments from the
promised neverland anime so far was it
as good as advertised
personally i would say the promise
neverland is one of the best surprises
that i've ever
ever witnessed because i went into it
with basically no expectations like i
didn't really know too much about the
concept
all i knew was that it was recommended
to me by a couple of people both on
patreon and in the youtube comments
so i checked it out it was only 12
episodes and it was
so good like i couldn't believe how good
it was
and after i finished i read the entire
manga over you know over the course of a
couple weeks
and the thing about the manga i know
people think it didn't end perfectly and
i can agree with that it didn't end
perfectly
however i couldn't help myself but to
read the next chapter i would get to a
point where i'd be like okay i'm going
to stop now
and then the chapter would finish and
i'd be like oh wait no i need to
continue this because the story is just
so good
um i say 70 to 80 of the story was
absolutely amazing
now talking about the anime specifically
one of my favorite moments was
uh rey being revealed as the traitor
quote unquote
the reason i like that moment is because
first of all norman is my favorite
character
so the fact that norman kind of like
outwitted rey and then
the reveal that rey is you know kind of
the bad guy but not really the bad guy
like i really love that moment
i was super shocked um but obviously
there's a ton of great moments as well
like when uh
the kids escaped like you know the whole
build up was to that moment so that was
obviously fantastic
and isabella's backstory that was
something else that
really like got me emotional actually
she wasn't always
evil you know she wasn't always this way
she basically had no choice
and that song that that was that guys
called leslie i think his name was
she had that song that she liked and
then ray freaking knew the song like
that was her son
nah that was amazing that was absolutely
amazing so yeah promise neverland
amazing series if you haven't seen it do
check it out i would i can't recommend
it enough
moving on to the youtube members tell
the tft says how was your 2020
also what's your plan for 2021 i'd say
for the most part 2020 was a good year
like it was a year of positive change
for me
a lot of big milestones happened in my
life that uh yeah that i didn't expect
when the year began
and a lot of that was thanks to the
support from you guys like helping me
out on youtube
towards the end of 2020 though i did
suffer from burnout
i found it hard to juggle like all the
videos i wanted to do along with doing
the twitch live streaming and just you
know having a life outside of youtube as
well
and to this day i still find it hard to
do that many of you may have noticed
that in january
of 2021 i didn't really upload as much
as i normally do
and that was because of the burnout like
i just found it hard to do
as many videos as i used to be able to
that said i still do have many plans for
um so for now currently i'm taking a
break from twitch so for those of you
who are waiting for me to return like i
don't know when i'll be back on twitch
right now i just need to focus on the
main channel because i'm not putting out
as much content as i want to
and uh yeah so i'm just focusing on on
getting back to where i was
one of my main goals this year is to get
a video editor to help me out at some
point
um because i feel like that's something
that would definitely help me put out
more content
because since the beginning of my
channel you know one and a half years
ago
all of it's been done by me so it would
help to have someone helping out with
just the the editing side of things
um but yeah we'll see what happens but i
hope that i can do that when season five
of my
academia comes out and the movie
obviously which we're looking forward to
i do think i'll be making a ton of
videos
so i feel like by then i should probably
have the editor situation sorted out but
knowing me i'll probably leave it till
the last minute
also regarding my academia i was taking
a break and i still am taking a break
from doing chapter reviews specifically
however that doesn't mean i'm not doing
my academia content next week you'll see
that i have a new video planned for
something else
but if you just look through the history
of this channel chapter reviews is
something i only started doing uh
consistently about six months ago
the vast majority of my content is not
chapter reviews you know i have
explanation videos theories um lists
a bunch of other stuff um so towards the
end of 2020 i felt like i was doing
chapter reviews
because i felt like i had to do them
rather than because i wanted to do them
this is probably a tip for every
youtuber out there who's watching this
it's best to like save your energy and
do the content you want
and right now the thing i'm most
enjoying is doing these episode reviews
for attack on titan
so many people appreciate it i see it in
the comments they'll watch the episode
of attack on titan and you know you just
need a breakdown you need someone to
explain certain things so i i love being
that person who can help
clear the series up for some people and
even though i'm taking a break from the
chapter reviews for now
they will obviously return but uh it
just depends when i get their motivation
it's all about motivation really you
can't force it what i am looking forward
to in 2021
is expanding more you know more videos
on black clover more videos on attack on
titan
diversifying the content is something
that i've always wanted to do for a
while
uh and yeah so this is the first steps
you know attack on titan was the first
real step um but we'll you'll see more
over the coming months
and uh yeah we'll see what happens
scooby nooby doo says
which titan form would you personally
want to have for me it would be the
beast titan
that is a good choice you know the beast
titan is not bad although it's a bit of
a lottery right like you don't
necessarily know which animal you're
gonna get so for me i'm gonna go with
the warhammer
i feel like the warhammer is the most
practical titan there is uh because you
know it's good from long range with the
crossbow and stuff but it's also good
from close range with with swords or
whatever you can create
i feel like whatever situation you're in
being the warmer titan you can probably
get yourself out of it
pippo says which pro hero do you think
should be higher in the hero rankings
than they are
i'm gonna go with gran torino because
when gran torino was first introduced
it was kind of implied that he wasn't
really that well known whatever rank he
is is probably not high enough
i mean this guy he survived multiple
encounters with all for one
he saved president mike during the war
arc he saved deku and bakugo during the
war arc
like those guys would have been dusted
if it wasn't for gran torino swooping in
and saving them
um and obviously he saved all my back in
the day so generally he's just
he's just awesome you know he's done so
much i would have gran torino up in like
25th place
somewhere high enough where you're like
you can respect it you know
um say gran torino gets my gets my vote
tungsten tacos says
what race would you like to see in black
clover for me i've always wanted to see
angels in black clover
because i think it's undeniable at this
point especially when we look at the
latest chapters
that devils are most likely the
strongest beings in this series
so like what is the inverse of the devil
well
it's an angel right so if devils are the
strongest then what are angels are they
even stronger
now um here's another thing angels don't
necessarily have to be good you know
like if angels are introduced they could
be villains before we know
but i would like to see them in some
form what do you guys think will angels
appear in this series or is it like
is this just a dream of mine that will
probably never happen let me know in the
comments below
on patreon balthazar says what other
media do you personally like outside of
anime
being books tv movies or video games
when it comes to video games i am a very
casual gamer
so recently i finished watchdog legion
which is the most fun i've had with any
game
for a few years most of the time this is
a really bad habit of mine
i'll get a game like for example i got
marvel avengers and i got samurai jack
i'll get a game and then i won't finish
it i just don't know why
so yeah i'm not a big gamer but at the
same time i do try i try at least
now when it comes to movies some of my
favorite movies of all time are
prometheus terminators one and two and
three as well actually three is quite
good
and uh interstellar gatica those are
some of my favorite movies of all time
so i think
i get that from my dad because he's a
big sci-fi fan as well regarding tv
shows modern family is the main thing
that i'm watching right now
i started it a couple of months ago with
my girlfriend and we've just been
watching it from the very beginning and
it has
an amazing cast and i say cam and mitch
are my favorite like
set of characters they're just too funny
anime addicts says what do you think
deku's capabilities with danger sense
will be
when he is able to fully use it to its
maximum potential
i had a thought that he could use it to
dodge attacks on par with observation
haki in one piece
so yeah i'm not too sure about
observation haki in one piece maybe
someone in the comments let me know
the full details of that however what i
can say is that at its maximum potential
danger sense could effectively be ultra
instinct just in the mighty academia
universe
because i feel like when you have a
power that alerts you when you're about
to be attacked
or when there's danger in the area then
the natural you know progression of that
is that you specifically know how people
are going to attack you whether it be
someone hitting him from behind
or someone trying to hit him with their
right fist instead of their left fist
like deku will specifically know the way
the attack is going to happen
and i guess in a way you could also
compare it to foresight which is a
sanitized quirk
but um yeah i feel like it would be
something that just makes deku
untouchable
um you know i mean when you have so many
quirks you're already overpowered so
why not why not just make him ultra
instinct deku i don't see a problem with
that
kronos says how do you feel about the
hero deaths in my academia
was it the right amount of casualties in
your opinion we didn't see any pussycats
or torino on the death camp pages
i expect torino's death will come in the
near future in the story but how do you
feel about the heroes like pussycats and
wash
making it through alive when it comes to
wash i feel like it made perfect sense
that he survived
because we saw his quirk in action you
know he was able to float people away
using his bubbles
so it only makes sense that he would
then use that on himself when it comes
to the pussycats that's a different
story
because when we have uh i believe it was
pixie bob she
erected these massive like walls of
earth and the decay still went past it
right so that was her defense the walls
were her defense to save her life and
everyone
else's and it failed you know the decay
still went past the walls
so the fact that she did survive when
the decay was this close
like looking at this panel it was right
there i find that unrealistic i don't
know how she survived i feel like the
pussycats
should have actually died based on that
situation in terms of key players we
didn't really lose that many people
now could it have been more definitely
definitely could have been more
um for example characters like mirko or
hawks
if they had died that would have been so
monumental
yes they may have injuries but the fact
is the situations they were in
if they had died would you really be
surprised like would you really be
surprised if mirko died after being in a
room with
five four or five no mu by herself would
it really been surprising if dabi had
flamed hawks as he said he was going to
do you know if tokyo army didn't appear
at the last moment hawks would have died
so they were very lucky you know what i
mean
the key players have been very lucky uh
this time around but um that's not me
saying that there weren't enough you
know there wasn't enough death and
destruction clearly there was a lot of
it
you know a lot of civilians died but i'm
just saying that for us to be even more
impacted as an audience
you know coming out of this war arc
midnight is the only real
character of significance to us who has
died i'd say most characters we like got
out of it alive
bronwyn quinn says what is your opinion
on minetta in my here academia
i've seen a lot of beef on tiktok over
him and his sexual harassment
and assault behaviors towards his
classmates and would like to hear your
opinion on this too
he's a creepy guy he is a creepy guy but
for the most part he's harmless i'd say
the only two times that i can think of
where he's across the line
number one is that thing he said to
everyone he was like uh come back to me
in a few years or something like that
um and another thing was when he was
trying to get into the girl's locker
room you know
obviously you shouldn't do that in real
life that is a form of harassment
but uh in terms of assault behaviors
i don't know of any assault behaviors
that i can think of off top of my head
anyway
for the most part his character is there
to be comedic relief of some kind
so i don't think he's meant to be uh as
sinister as maybe some people think he
is
the last question of this video comes
from joseph and he says
when this series was in development
midnight was stated to be
the class 1a homeroom teacher if that
didn't change
does she still die during the war arc i
didn't actually know this fact
but if midnight was the homeroom teacher
then it stands to reason that her level
of relevance to the story
would almost be similar to what izawa's
is
obviously you know you're talking about
the early days when the series was in
development
so in theory you know midnight could
have had izawa's quirk he's a razor
quirk
like we don't exactly know what haruko
she was thinking back then
now does she die if she's the homeroom
teacher probably not probably not
i mean midnight was the most important
person who died and let's be perfectly
honest she is a side character
the students definitely feel the impact
but i'm just talking about from
perspective as an
audience like midnight was important yes
but she is still a side character
anyway guys that was the end of the q a
for this month thank you for your
support and don't forget to drop this
video a like as it does help out the
channel
i have a few interesting videos planned
for the coming weeks so be sure to stick
around for that and until the next one
peace out